but first tonight corruption and abuse
of power
the fbi agent at the center of the
russia collusion lie
sentenced today with no jail time and no
fines
despite altering the document which
enabled the fbi to spy on an
innocent american citizen for a year
kevin kleinsmith sentenced to 12 months
probation and 400 hours of community
service
no jail time a slap on the wrist for
lying and doctoring an email about trump
advisor carter page
so that the fbi could get a fisa warrant
to wiretap him
this is the first guilty plea from
special counsel john durham's criminal
investigation on the origins of the
russia collusion lie
coming up the man at the center of that
lie targeted because he was associated
with donald trump
carter page is here tonight with
reaction after getting wiretapped for a
year with no
chargers ever lobbed against him
but first the lawmaker who first
uncovered the fraud more than three
years ago
intelligence committee ranking member
devin nunes with reaction
to this latest fbi controversy he's the
author of the book
countdown to socialism congressman it's
good to see you tonight thanks very much
for being here
thank you your reaction to kevin
kleinsmith and this slap on the wrist
it's uh i would say quite disturbing
republicans and conservatives
around the country that have watched
this closely
this is probably the worst thing that
could have happened for national
security
the judge that made this ruling is the
new judge that oversees the fisa court
for nearly four years republicans in the
house and the senate had alerted
the court that there was a problem with
the carter page
fisa application we called it fisa abuse
you covered it on your sunday morning
show for many years maria
so where we go from here i think is it's
going to become part of the party
platform
uh that republicans are not going to be
for the fisa court
uh and that's an unfortunate thing to
say because you've
they've backed republicans and
conservatives across the country
into a corner to make that tough choice
between liberty and security uh and i'm
sorry
at the end of the day uh republicans are
going to pick liberty and freedom
and we watch what's happening you know
with these big tech companies
coming in and obliterating companies
from the map
uh while at the same time you see the
lead justice of the fisa court and obama
point a point d
essentially apologize uh acted like that
clint smith was somehow a victim
so it's actually brought shame not just
on the fisa court but this
judge this judge also the whole thing
seems it's very very disheartening to
say the least
you said congressman that this is really
too bad for national security
connect the dots here for us what are
you referring to
well look the fisa programs have been in
place now for what for
four decades or so uh after 9 11 there
were a couple of important programs that
were put in one of those expired last
year
uh look my guess is is that that moving
forward
uh you're going to see legislation that
there were a few republicans who were
out there that were raising these
concerns
i actually kind of rejected those
concerns because i said look
we just have a few bad apples here but
now when you see the lead judge of the
fisa court
essentially apologize and act like that
kleinsmith is some kind of a victim
um look you just can't miss republicans
you just can't make excuses for this
anymore so
how do you go to your how do we go to
our constituents as members of congress
members of the senate and say that
yeah well yeah they went there they did
spy on the republican party they did
take a bunch of innocent americans like
carter page who's going to be on next
ruined his life uh and then when we got
to the bottom of it after
years and years and a special counsel
and the attacks
everybody involved in the media you know
that you covered so well
then at the end of the day they give a
slap on the wrist i mean you know
tonight
i wouldn't be surprised if klein smith
is over partying
with the judges as if this is some kind
of joke it's almost like they're in on
it
well uh senator ted cruz joined me to
talk
about the fbi malfeasance and he
encapsulated really what client smith
did very well
here's senator ted cruz on sunday
morning futures back in december
so carter page is an outside advisor to
the trump campaign
he also is periodically talking to
russians including some sketchy russians
and so the fbi wants to get a wiretap on
him
so the fbi sends an email to the cia
says hey is this guy a source for you
the cia emails back and they say yes
he's a source the fbi assistant general
counsel takes that email
and he alters it he types in the word so
fb
cia said yes he's a source the fbi
lawyer types in
no he is not a source unbelievable 180
degrees exactly opposite
he then sends that email on to the
department of justice that uses that as
the basis for a sworn statement to the
fisa court
to get a wiretap this
is the most obvious straightforward
criminality and yet no jail time
not even a fine congressman do you think
they are using his guilty plea as a way
to take
others down is that what this is about
look i i i don't think there's any
excuse for it i mean it looks like total
corruption all the way to the top
there's no excuse
whatsoever i mean this was so blatant it
was so
obvious you changed the wording you took
somebody like carter page who had
who was a naval academy graduate he had
done work for the cia
so you know when you talk about you know
you we as
as in the intelligence world you like to
have americans if they're working under
the cia
as sources if they're going to moscow
that they're bringing information back
and giving that back to the cia
and and by the way carter page was very
helpful in some of these prosecutions so
imagine being carter page to see this
happen where you have somebody who's
clearly guilty this wasn't just
this the house intelligence committee
republicans this was also the inspector
general
it was the special counsel now john
durham nothing's going to happen this
guy people want to know
why why is nothing happening there's not
a good answer
is there anything that's going to happen
to anybody john durham apparently still
working on this are you expecting
indictments anytime
soon well i think that becomes the
question you have 95
of the district of columbia voted uh for
uh uh for biden um you have
all the media essentially continuing to
lie about this russia hoax
you have all the russia hoaxers have
been promoted into the biden
administration
people who were doing multiple
unmaskings lying about it to the media
people that were peddling
uh the secret p tapes the p dossiers
and then lo and behold you have the
judge the leading judge that's in charge
of the fisa court that's based out of
washington dc
essentially give almost an atta boy like
hey
look look at make sure we're going to
make an example of kleinsmith
if you do what the democratic party
wants we're going to reward you you may
get hit with a hurricane i think the
judge head of bad media and bad press
but don't worry we're going to be there
to protect you any of you fbi agents out
there watching doj officials
long as you're working for obama biden
the left
big tech it's okay that's what the judge
said today
and i don't see how there's a future uh
for any republican who's gonna
tolerate uh you know these these fisa
powers that are that have now been
abused
and now criminally abused and now you
let people walk and skate
so are you saying you will reject you
will vote against
the renewal of these fisa programs when
they come up
is that next year i don't know of a
republican look part of the problem here
is
is the fisa part that was passed back in
the late 70s
that's in permanent law so now we're
going to have to look at okay how do you
take that law apart
nobody was ever there i mean and that
just happened today
if klein smith would have got he should
have received the maximum sentence
the maximum any any idiot out there
that's not partisan would know he should
receive the maximum sentence
instead you're out now tonight and i'm
being facetious but you can go out to a
bar and party the restaurants are open
in washington dc
you can even go party with this judge if
you want it's ridiculous
congressman it's good to have you
tonight thanks very much you've done a
lot of work on this
and we appreciate it my next guest is
the subject of that fbi crooked
investigation
he's the author of the book abuse and
power how an innocent american was
framed in an attempted
coup against the president joining me
right now is carter page himself
carter thanks very much for being here
how are you feeling tonight
maria there as you as you were just
discussing with congressman nunes
this has been a long ongoing battle and
for the first time today i had the
opportunity to talk
with a the top judge on the fisa court
and yes i understand uh several of
uh congressman nunes concerns but the
difference is
he he actually it was the first
opportunity to have any dialogue
whatsoever
and i have been totally stonewalled by
everyone
so i i understand there are there are
some big open questions
uh going back to the uh nunes memo which
he uh led uh almost three years ago
i think there's a lot of things that
still uh remain unanswered but
i think we're uh you know the fact that
there's a new dialogue
the the judge i will disagree with him a
little bit
he he actually did note uh some serious
concerns regarding the
abuses in the the fisa process and we
had a uh
a good dialogue regarding that and i i i
still have some hope that there might be
some possibilities in the future here
well look carter your life was disrupted
i mean
devin nunes just said your life was
ruined tell us what happened
when your name started showing up in the
press as somebody who was colluding with
russia
back in 2017 what happened to you
as you were then wiretapped by the fbi
maria this is very similar to what's
going on now i've just
been fighting for the truth and i think
exactly as he
uh congressman nunes mentioned there has
just been so much false
information they had this multi-million
dollar
dossier project which was designed to
take out candidate trump uh which then
was a terrible disruption
on the trump administration for many
many years
so unfortunately they just used my name
with all these falsehoods
so it was a very long pattern of
wrongdoing and the one thing i would
note if you look at the very specifics
if you reread the
nunes memo he talks about a lot of very
senior people
within the doj and the fbi who were
involved
in this fisa abuse and yes it's true
that um
you know there are there are some
terrible things that happened with mr
kleinsmith
however uh he was a relatively small
player so i think
you know this investigation is ongoing
and we're gonna have to see what comes
out of it
yeah i mean i was talking about the
death threats that you have told me
about in the past
uh they clearly undermined the fisa
process
undermined our democracy and then lied
about it
jim comey was asked about the fisa
process
and how they came about getting a
wiretap on you
for a year listening to your calls
watching your emails your texts etc
here's what jim comey said about the
pfizer process when he was asked about
it back in 2018.
listen to this a total confidence that
the fisa process
was followed and that the entire case
was handled in a thoughtful responsible
way by doj and the fbi
i think the notion that pfizer was
abused here is nonsense
what do you say to that
well again there are there's a lot
he was completely disproven
a little a little over a year later with
the
fisa abuse report by the inspector
general and unfortunately
we still don't have all the truth about
that as well
again that was what the major step
forward is in terms of having a direct
dialogue
with the foreign intelligence
surveillance court uh
presiding judge today i was completely
blocked by mr horowitz the doj
inspector general so i think this uh
there's actually some reasons for
significant optimism and it's great
that people are standing up and calling
for
justice and a reform to our system
and the nice thing is i heard some
positive
importance statements that the judge
made today about that and
again there are a lot more senior people
who had
much greater knowledge and had much
greater control and i think there
definitely needs to be some
accountability and i keep the faith that
that will eventually happen
yeah we've been we've been looking for
accountability for a long time carter
you are suing the department of justice
the fbi
jim comey saying that there was unlawful
surveillance of you
a 75 million lawsuit where does that
stand
tonight carter uh that is
still in the early stages the services
process has been
completed and now uh we will uh we'll go
through the
initial stages in terms of uh
preliminary procedures with that so
we shall see again i keep i keep
significant faith that
of eventually justice will be served in
that same court the d.c district court
we hope so because when justice is not
served
the people do not believe in our
institutions
and this of course has been a black eye
on the fbi
carter it's good to see you tonight
thanks very much for talking about it
with us
tonight carter page thanks so much maria